it was an uncomfortable prime minister's
questions for Rishi sunak I thought
mortgages of course at the center of the
discussion I mean whether or not it's a
catastrophe that's the question that
that cares Dharma opened by asking
um that's a word by the way used by Tory
mp uh Lucy Allen the outgoing Telford MP
in a tweet last Friday uh or not it is a
very very big problem and we've probably
got we've probably got rate risers
tomorrow and so I was very interested to
look at how the Prime Minister dealt
with the questions from Kirsten I I
wonder whether or not it isn't worth
them in Downing Street sitting down with
him and re-watching prime minister's
questions because a number of things
struck in case they're listening because
a number of things struck me about his
support he he obviously was quite he's
angry he looks angry to me you can see
that whenever you see his teeth he sort
of know that he's quite he's he's
irritable and he's and and what he does
bad rashids and stuff it's lecturing
people and there's quite a lot of
lecturing there's a absolutely it was a
sort of he talked about people not
paying attention to what he was saying
and he talked about kiss time and not
understanding the macroeconomic
situation you know this is a very big
and bold and tricky issue for every
party there are no easy solutions and I
and I just wonder whether how that tone
uh where you're basically saying no no
no no you don't understand just just
whether that is is a particularly Prime
ministerial way I think at this point
where uh mortgages are raising so so far
so fast you know one individual a
policeman quoted uh by kirst armor 400
pounds a month let's hear some of the
way that kirst armor uh talked about the
problem
that's the cost to the average family of
the Tory mortgage penalty now he was
warned by experts about this as long ago
as Autumn last year but it either didn't
get it didn't believe it or didn't care
because he certainly didn't do anything
and when I raised this a couple of
months ago he had the goal to stand at
that dispatch box and say he was
delivering for homeowners
how is an extra 2 900 pounds a year of
repayment delivering for homeowners
[Applause]
talks about interest rates he talks
about interest rates perhaps all
gentlemen could explain why interest
rates are at similar levels in the
United States in Canada in Australia and
New Zealand why they're at the highest
level in Europe that they've been for
two decades Mr Speaker that's why it's
important that we have a plan to reduce
inflation but in contrast what do we
hear from one more gentlemen he wants to
borrow an extra 28 billion pounds a year
that would make the situation worse he
wants to ban new supplies of energy from
the North Sea that would make the
situation worse and and he wants to give
in to Union's unaffordable pay demands
that would make the situation worse Mr
Speaker he doesn't have many policies
but the few that he does have all have
the same thing in common they're
dangerous inflationary and working
people would pay the price
that's the response line we've seen
isn't it from the government before that
laborers you turned on their spending
plans they say that what what they're
planning it is not affordable but when
you get the leader of the opposition
saying 2 900 pounds a year that's what
sticks in people's minds isn't it it's
not
listening to arguments about exogenous
shocks and Global pressures and all
those other things it's the money in
your pocket absolutely Dentistry know
that the money in your pocket is what's
going to determine the next election and
the Relentless rise of interest rates
off the back of higher than expected and
persistent inflation is the thing that's
going to take money out of people's
pockets and quite possibly uh with
electoral consequence next year and
Richard Scenic today had two basic types
of argument one was to say look this is
happening everywhere but but the worry
in the city and I've talked to a few
businesses that actually Britain is
starting to get in the worst position in
other countries Richardson mentioned
America you know it was seven days ago
that U.S fed officials was starting to
flow to kind of pause in interest rate
Rises because of the the underlying data
over over there and core inflation which
is what we saw going up here today which
makes the government's argument that
actually they're getting inflation on
the under control it makes their
argument difficult in the United States
in German the core inflation is coming
down and and so the the root of global
comparisons is is only of so much
utility for uh for for Rishi Cena the
other technique that he has is to say
label to spend more and that could push
up inflation now uh I think that's I
think many economists would agree that
that is potentially an issue labor
actually sort of slowed the path of that
additional spending and additional
borrowing in the last few days when it
comes to that uh comes to their green
projects
um but but what people didn't hear a
great deal of is what the government are
going to do that's because there are no
easy answers because any big expensive
seed scheme that we saw the sort that we
saw with with Energy prices is a too
expensive and B will probably push up
inflation and therefore interest rates
and make the situation worse and and
that's the conundrum that both parties
have a neighbor can't can't have a a
clear answer to that uh particularly
what they can do is try and plan as much
blame for what's going on on the
conservative I think that's where that's
where the case is far more contestable
that's whether I think it's harder to
see that labor can blame the government
for for some of the things that are
going on here given the reason that the
UK is going in the wrong direction
um partly to do with um specific things
like the way that we went into furlough
what the legacy of the fellow scheme
that means that people are getting back
into office getting back into work
slower than in other countries or the
fact that we're more they can lay the
blame which is the next door which they
they could do it it's I mean I'm not
sure whether labor are going to go out
full-throated and condemn the
felloweskeep that they agreed with at
the time or the fact that Britain is
very reliant on gas boilers much more so
than for instance in France so when
Rishi sinat blames Global problems
actually you know political advisors in
his own government admit that there are
UK specific factors that are the real
problem here that are not there are any
part due to government decision making
often government decision making at a
different point to deal with a different
crisis that was backed by the opposition
at the time so it's not clear that
there's a a as clear a dividing line
over that as there is uh uh as labor
would want there to be so that the kind
of blame game I think doesn't
necessarily help labor automatically on
the basis of the facts as I as I see
them but the but the problem is
Richardson hasn't yet developed a
language that is reassuring uh that
explains what might be able to be done
around the margins uh and how people can
deal with 400 pounds on people's
mortgages a month that is unsustainable
for almost everybody and and and there
just wasn't anything in the tone of the
Prime Minister or the substance really
that that acknowledged a sort of what
will be individual catastrophes on that
skill yeah and we're expecting a rate
rise aren't we coming through tomorrow
not nearly everybody in the city thinks
it's going to be at least a quarter of a
percent uh let's not make uh Burns about
this it's going to be a key electoral
issue isn't it it is and um there is a
there is a group inside the conservative
party that would really love to blame
Andrew Bailey the governor of the bank
of England running arguments that he
started raising interest rates too late
and therefore Britain has to go go
further but because of what happened in
the Liz truss era essentially this
government Rishi sunak has decided that
he cannot criticize and him and Jeremy
Hunt cannot criticize Andrew Bailey
because of the possibility of Market
turbulence additional Market turbulence
that that would that would cause so
blaming him is effectively off the table
at the moment for Tory politicians as
they cast around looking for uh for
villains in this but in the end I think
uh people will look uh at the situation
at what the government presents as as
what it's doing and and draw their own
conclusions